[Music]
all right joel khan i think this is
your third appearance on the podcast but
it's been a while yeah it's been
i don't know the numbers probably two
years right you came to a hotel in l.a
and then once i came to your right that
first time that had to be four years ago
yeah he was like maybe number 38 don't
quote me on that but it was pretty early
and congrats on the thank you book
number five comes out tomorrow right
last week oh it did oh cool awesome man
january one you've written like
four books fifth book five books wow
that's amazing well we're going to get
into it yeah that's no problem
all right i have no time cool go long
set a record i'll do tim ferriss
whatever yeah joe rogan
will you cry for me yeah it was powerful
i'll cry um good well i'm excited to uh
to
reprise uh our ongoing conversation and
i think a good way to kind of
get into this is to kind of canvas
what's going on right now in the
conversation around
nutrition at large because i feel like
and i know you agree
there is a war afoot for hearts and
minds
and the battle lines seem to have been
drawn
and on the one side we have the
ascending popularity
of the low carb high fat slash
ketogenic slash intermittent fasting
camp and amongst the proponents
of that uh philosophy
or approach to nutrition we have
people like uh dr rasim malhortza
cardiologist yes we have professor tim
knox we have gary taubs we have robert
lustig
people like mark sisson dr mercola on
the other side
we have the plant-based camp we have
yourself
leading the charge and at the tip of
that spear also we have garth davis we
have dr
michael greger we have dr dean ornish dr
esselstyn
dr michael clapper milton mills a whole
bunch of other people i'm sure i'm
forgetting
but this seems to be kind of where
things are at
in the current dialogue or debate around
what is the optimal way to
eat right and you have been
pretty vociferous and active in terms of
your blogging
and television appearances and books and
you know
your stuff i don't know where you find
the time to write all these blog posts
mind body green and on thrive global
and medium everywhere i look every other
day i get a text or an email from you
new post up
so you're very active in trying to uh
you know communicate and participate
in this dialogue so how do you see
things now
uh you know what's going on yeah i agree
with you and um
you know that's the list you
read and the two sides of which there's
many you know
great luminaries robert osfield
cardiologists right
many others so many others if i start
naming them then i'm going to forget
that
i definitely would add neenah titles on
the dark side
for sure a big fat surprise um
it's very confusing i think forget
the most important topic which is
where's the truth in the discussion
for human health and human well-being
and longevity and joy
and freedom for medication and need for
medical procedures which is really
the real issue as close as we can get to
knowing the answer that that is the best
service we're going to be doing to
ourselves our family and the public
um it is a ugly
ugly um situation that's very polarized
yet there is middle ground and i mean i
don't want to
you know begin at the ending but the
the thing i'll acknowledge if you go
back to lauren cordain and the paleo
diet book which
frankly if most plant-based people read
it they'd say i agree
90 of this book and is the
shunning of piper processed fast food
the thing that's decimating the health
of the western world
both camps will agree um
are exited although i'll say of course
our junk food vegans
that have confused both the mission
and the argument we have that this is a
very healthy lifestyle
and the other side has confused it by
reintroducing dairy and bringing butter
back
and now you know even cheese when
originally that was never a part of
the low carb high fat and certainly
paleo today yeah paleo shoot dairy
ultimately they shoot dairy but now you
know
depending on you know what version of
that um all of a sudden goat cheese is
back and goat milk
back and certainly butter is back in
various versions so
i mean the common ground i had the
opportunity about uh
a few months ago to go over to
googleplex in mountain view and it was
arranged via kip anderson and there was
a conversation
in front of a a hundred of the google uh
young people but beamed all over google
worldwide and the
the conversation they set up for us was
these are real people
real health issues real health concerns
real goals don't just have a fight and
leave them confused because what does
the public do when they're confused they
do whatever the heck they want
and that's the point i wanted to make um
we are we are left with this polarized
discussion that
leads most people and very intelligent
people and people even in this sector of
the health world and the
food world and the medical world to say
you guys are
so disparate i moderation everything
i'll do whatever i want
and that's unfortunately not serving us
well so i'd rather highlight you know
the common ground which is
none of us are into excess sugar we can
define none or low but none of us are
index is sugar
none of us are into fast food i don't
know that anybody on their side or
outside is talking about eating fried
food with any regularity
i mean they're not big into bacon and i
don't think they did they'd
advocate hot dogs and salami and bologna
and obviously that's not even on our
menu
uh which is all in advance i mean so
that and then
you know a lot of leafy greens i would
not stop at leafy greens i'd go into
lots of fruits and lots of root
vegetables and starchy vegetables
but i mean maybe the first step
is for all united parties to say
you know school kids hospital patients
airports vending people in the workplace
whether they're of low socioeconomic
high socioeconomic
we need to get this junk out which is a
you know a
a an impossible job when you got wendy's
and
uh kfc and mcdonald's and you know these
gigantic multi-billion dollar
conglomerates
that i think you know it'll take 10
years and they'll be doing a better job
not a perfect job anyways there is a lot
of commonality yet
you're absolutely right i wake up every
morning after a few minutes of gratitude
and spend a few minutes perusing the
internet what's new overnight and i kind
of have my sequence to go through and
it's either a hot new article on
ketogenic or it's a hot new article
usually about another vegan restaurant
opening in london or somewhere but
they're very
they're very separate and there isn't
much uh
discussion this google talk with dave
asprey of the bulletproof nutrition
group and kip anderson myself was one
you know one of the rare times you're
not going to see you talking at paleo fx
or
me being invited to uh going to the
lines then so
i look forward to that happening i think
without doubt we have science on our
side and we can
you know that's always my touchstone uh
recognizing it's very hard to parse out
there's deficiencies we don't have large
randomized studies
in many of these topics do we know
enough to talk about what is the optimal
diet for the human species and we do
and it's much more weighted towards our
choice of diet
even if you just talk nutrition take
away the environment take away animal
rights just talk nutrition
we are on the right path and i mean i'm
emboldened by that by some
recent scientists who've come out kind
of independently with no axe to grind
that
the diet you feed your family rich the
diet i feed my family and in my
restaurant
in detroit um the public will be able to
identify that this is
where they need to move towards uh
even though all this confusion exists
well i think it's happening i mean
the ascendancy of just plant-based
awareness in the last couple years
alone has been pretty dramatic and and i
think it's
showing indications that it's not a fad
that it is here to stay and it's
building and that's really cool
um you know but there is this debate the
debate gets very emotional it gets
heated
and that's the spirit in which i pulled
up
youtube and decided to watch your your
event at google
with you and kip and dave and i had i
guess i had a preconceived
idea that it was going to devolve into
not mudslinging but
kind of get a little bit heated in that
regard and i was
quite pleasantly surprised to find that
that was not the case
um you were kind of the peacemaker i
felt like
but i found dave to be pretty amenable
to
almost everything that you were saying i
mean kipp and him you know kind of
butted heads a little bit
over some of the environmental stuff but
overall i find you
i found you guys coming to uh you know a
common sense ability on most of the
top shelf big ticket items yeah i agree
and um
that was set up as please try and
give us practical and important tips
again this
wasn't hollywood and a tv show where
you know ugliness can be quite
successful in terms of a marketing
strategy
this was you know real people needing
real advice and
you know i don't agree with a lot of
what dave asprey does and talks about
um and there's you know no science that
he's produced that can support butter in
your coffee and
and his experience in tibet with yak uh
tea and all the
i think nonsense that uh all that story
is and you know how the public loves a
great story but
um but when you talk about a diet very
high in cruciferous vegetables and whole
foods and
uh absent excess sugar and absent you
know junk food i mean there is that
uh i would eat at his house he would in
my house in fact the
untold story there is when we went to
the google cafeteria after that
hour-long talk
and we were catching in the last 10
minutes he had the toughest time of all
of us
i mean kip and i had no problem eating
there but we're trying to find something
yeah fine fine you know everything that
met his list was tougher to me than ours
and in fact he found
a big plate um i think it was just
greens and he always carries mct oil of
his own derivation
um and it was like he was the most uh
orthodox uh
kosher of the group kind of impression
because he puts
as i said these we are all teaching
rather unfortunately now i would i call
it elitist diets i mean
we i don't know how many people we speak
to do we speak to 10
of america sorry and i just knocked
saying over on your desk
and my little uh yeah you have a yoga a
soldier as a yoga
yeah it is of course you know how many
are we talking to but
um you know i hope we can expand the
conversation
and uh and reach out to you know close
to 100 percent
when the right thing to do is easy thing
to do when mcdonald's has healthy
options when
you know schools and hospitals have
healthy options i think the food
industry is like a bright light of
what's going on they're ignoring
this debate and just putting more and
more you know healthier options
plant-based options
out there but yeah it was a it was a
good experience there was
the other backstory just to make your
audience laugh is i
still use my aol email so i know i'm the
only speaker ever to be invited to an at
google talks
who set it all up via my aol i have
gmail accounts i just
like uh i like the appearance of aol
and and then that's reviews
and i of course i asked him do you still
use yeah well yeah a surprising number
of closet people like me i think they
should just rename it aold
because if you're old enough to have one
just be proud of your seniority card
aold and um and the the
the final retribution was that they were
supposed to post that talk uh the day it
happened it took them six weeks they had
a youtube flaw
and they were you know they kept
apologizing and i kept responding in my
aol email well
i'm pretty high tech care i'll just be
patient and wait they ultimately got it
up to youtube but um
you know but but it is the uh you know
in silicon valley where we have this
discussion i mean business insider
magazine and such the ketogenic diet is
very popular right now the idea that uh
really strictly eliminating carbs of and
we always have to be careful in the
definition
carbs are you know plants have food has
usually carbs protein and fat in almost
every food until you refine it the
coconut has all those and
and olive has all those once you refine
it you may end up with only fat
so all foods have the three
macronutrients i don't think there's any
exception to that maybe different
percentages
so a low-carb diet of course many of
them continue to eat
a decent amount of greens in their diet
but they're eliminating all
the whites and they're hyper vigilant
about it the big difference in the
ketogenic diet are you doing high fat
low carb low protein which you can talk
about and with a plant-based approach
may actually have some
benefit in science or are you doing a
low carb
high fat and high protein diet which
probably ages you quicker than any other
diet on the planet
and that isn't always parsed out in
their conversation
so the scary skeleton in the ketogenic
diet closet is you'll lose weight
you may have some boost in energy for a
period of time you may be increasing
your mortality risk
um and they just don't talk about that
with great regularity so
it's a it's a difficult diet and i think
dave ashby trying to eat in the google
i i don't know that he'd want to be
cornered as a ketogenic diet proponent
he has his brand bulletproof diet
but you know the difficulty he had my
patients telling me this is you know on
the road
it's easier to be plant-based than it is
to eat a strict ketogenic diet right now
of
you know high-fat options you're going
to have to carry around your own food
but the gravest concern is is it a
healthy pattern
is there any natural population and even
slightly approaches it and has done well
long term
kind of a bullet shot at the plant-based
movement show me a society that's been
plant-based for centuries and has
thrived
that's one of nina's big points big
points but show me a community that's
you can talk about eskimos in the
messiah who lived to age 30 or 40 well
that's not kind of the
example we're talking about show a
okinawa type population that was
90 plus plant-based and thrive great we
have our
our example that approximates the way we
eat
uh they have great difficulty with that
in fact the scientific data is it's the
converse that they are
at risk shortening their lifespan if
it's an animal-based
low-carb diet particularly if they're
emphasizing foods
that they feel are high in protein which
are typically going to be meats
of a variety of kinds no matter whether
it's grass-fed or not it's the basic
constitution of animal
muscle that can age you excessively and
the science is well known
so a couple observations on that uh
first with respect to
the the degree of difficulty of
maintaining a ketogenic diet it's an
interesting
um thing to talk about because
you're right like to actually do a
ketogenic diet
properly requires an incredible amount
of like a forethought and planning and
displacement
it's not easy to really dial that in and
make it work
compared to a plant-based diet and yet i
feel like
the plant-based diet gets unduly
criticized for being restrictive and too
difficult and
something that people are just never
going to be able to maintain long-term
despite the fact that both of us have
done that
but people are very quick to jump on the
ketogenic bandwagon
and try it with enthusiasm without that
same concern being applied yeah i agree
completely you know just a couple
examples there's uh
joe rogan had a surgeon on um
shawn baker and i don't know sean baker
very well we go at each other a little
bit on twitter
and he said very you know casually even
he's an md
i've done and the ultimate example of
these diets is there's a whole group of
people eating nothing but meat three
meals a day and literally nothing but
meat
and for reasons i don't completely
understand carnivore guy
yeah and he's one of many i mean he's
not the only one that shows up there
they can claim short term some pretty
impressive pictures of their abs and
weight and some of them have some heart
ct data of course there's nothing
published in the literature i want to
come back to that
but you know dr baker said i didn't even
bother to check my labs joe hogan said
you've been doing this for a year he
goes no i
didn't check my labs well i have
patients that do that and they get their
labs checked not under my advice
and i have one that i'm going to write
up maybe on the airplane flight back to
detroit later
uh this evening um his cholesterol went
from two i've never seen this 250 to
750.
during the two months he did a meat only
diet trying to approximate what he was
hearing on these
you know rogue not rogan kind of
podcasts
um and it's insanity and it's it's like
religious
fervor and uh follow the leader without
thoughtfulness
um the only medical condition that has
any data everybody can verify this
pubmed.com
put in ketogenic diet refractory
epilepsy in children and some degree
adults
have a number i mean several dozen
published studies
on a impact if standard drugs like
dilating don't work and in fact before
dylan
ketogenic diet was a reasonable choice
for
kids with epilepsy as soon as drugs came
out it kind of faded off and has come
back for that use
daniel aymond very famous local
psychiatrist
and a friend has a grandson that had
refractory seizures
rather sadly and ironically ketogenic
diet was very beneficial
you go beyond that you're just you're
you're absent data so
another startup that's hot and it's
worth talking about because
your listeners will hear this is verta
health
backed by stephen finney md i don't know
much about him he appeared in
dr malhotra's documentary about visiting
the home of
ansel keys one of the most distorted and
misleading documentaries
ever done called the the peop diet
pio ppi don't read it don't watch it
it's a waste time money and
honesty but virta health claims with a
ketogenic diet that you can reverse
your type 2 diabetes with a high
frequency and they've got a lot of
backing
and they've got an app and they've got
you know a coaching system
so they have published a study in a
journal that is so obscure
and so non-reputable but it is a journal
which is a proliferation of scientific
journals that are open and
you can either pay to publish an article
or get access
but it's a small study of six months
duration actually
originally 10 weeks duration
non-randomized no control group
in the scientific world this is about as
low as it goes and yes with the dietary
plan they advocated
very high dropout rate in the group
studied they showed some
drop in measures of diabetic control
towards the better
with their ketogenic diet coaching
system and on that
i speak to like brilliant people and
they say well the debate's over virta
health has shown that
ketogenic diet can solve multiple health
problems
it's so overblown and in fact what's
missing is the six seven studies that
suggest
to get to the point big studies hundreds
of thousands of people these are
association studies
group of people ate a certain way
questionnaires food questionnaires once
food questionnaires
several times during a number of years
follow these people up harvard school
public health
tough school nutrition very prominent
places a dramatic rise in long-term
mortality by people's
whose food pattern
it can be called a low carb high fat
diet a rise in death rate
if you've had a heart attack and you
fill out questionnaires at the harvard
school public health and they follow you
long term
and your diet can be described as a low
carb high fat diet you're much more
likely to
die and follow up than people that
describe diets that are closer to
high carb hopefully complex plant
choices though these aren't vegans
you know more like a mediterranean style
diet so that's the untold story for
anybody listening and it's falling for
this
optimization of performance and
metabolism and
control of cardiovascular risk the data
needs to be addressed
about death rate and until there's a
study that resolves that issue
and and says that's wrong six seven
different studies in different parts of
the world
i could not in any good conscience
advise somebody do a
animal-based low-carb ketogenic pattern
particularly if it's high in protein
protein activates aging pathways protein
activates biochemical pathways
that right here in the city of the
angels have been found from yeast to
mice to humans to
cause accelerated aging and aging in
every
aspect of our body and it is animal
protein rich in an amino acid called
leucine is the main trigger and you
can't get around it grass-fed
beef free-range chicken and lime caught
fish all have tremendously more leucine
than the amino acid
acid structure of plants they have it
but they don't have near the same amount
so when you raise those concerns and
those issues
and make those points what is the
resource
um association is not causation
you know so what i've done a few times
is take the argument that particularly
nina teichels the author of the big fat
surprise
number one nonfiction book in the health
arena in 2014
and to this day still celebrated as some
kind of
heavenly light that the nutrition world
has accepted as
despite absence of phds or nutritional
science backgrounds and she'd argue you
don't need those things you just need to
study
lots of people talk nutrition that don't
necessarily have mds phds
rd's and all the rest has been accepted
to the point in late 2017
the british medical journal lancet one
of the most respected and
wrote a review of her 2014 book three
years later as if it had just come out
as if it was novel praised it as if she
had bought an ad in the
leading medical journal in the uk it's
it's just insanity so
she will argue and dissected the movie
what the health
and first what things she did and i'll
get back to you
this is the answer question i don't
remember it was 39 major health claims
made in the movie what the hell
she threw 37 of them away because either
dr bernard dr greger myself dr
uh mills uh and all vegan
doctors can't be trusted to give
credible medical
research summaries because we're biased
so she that was one of her rules
she has a second rule a statistical role
if the risk described in a
if if you drop your risk of diabetes by
less than
50 it's not strong statistical data
and and so she only was willing to give
us one or two of the claims
in the movie what the health is possibly
scientifically valid of course anything
that is
association not causation you have to do
like a randomized study and understand
the basic mechanism
so i've gone to some of the um
ketogenic data and a study called the
pure study that really confused the
world in late 2017.
said let's apply nina's rules okay dr
saleem yusuf the lead author eats meat
so we have to throw him out anything
he's
you know it becomes farcical i mean i i
and i've said this public and i'd say it
again the day that dean ornish does a
randomized study that says
heart artery blockage reverses with beef
chicken and you know and pork my
obligation as a cardiologist is probably
to advise a patient there's new data
that's credible and you should consider
even though it kills me and it kills the
animals and it's bad for the environment
it's it's not the case and um and
we didn't we don't need to go down that
path so
what did they say association not
causation
vegan doctors uh weak data um
or they don't respond um because they
have their
events and as you've pointed out with
other people who've interviewed they
seem a little more organized and a
little more manly and a little more
vibrant but i think we're coming on
strong in the
medical health plant-based world with
hunky people like you
and scott stoll former olympic athlete
and such
the uh the contention the argument that
no uh no medical authority no doctor
who is a long time vegan or plant-based
person can be
trusted or is inherently
conflicted because of that point of view
and
and as such you know their perspective
or their opinion on all of these issues
should be
invalidated is uh disingenuous because
that the level of of investment that
the other side has in their own movement
is
equal if not you know if if not more
entrenched
so if you're going to apply that rule um
you know equally it would just eradicate
everybody but human beings were
you know we we flock to our tribes right
we inherently
want to be a member of a team and that
doesn't necessarily serve anybody
and once we become entrenched whether
you're plant-based ketogenic whatever it
becomes more and more difficult to be
objective like i'd like to think like
yourself if evidence came out that what
i was
the way i was eating and living was
harmful to myself
or to the planet or anything else that i
would have the objectivity
to then really look at that take
ownership of that and and make changes
in my life
yeah so um would i i don't know yeah
like people would say well i'm so
you know this is my brand now there's no
way that i could ever you know
there is that i mean that's you know
watching when what the health came out
and there was a lot of praise for the
movie for about two weeks
and then those that have a following
have to respond i mean they have to
and and what the health we should get
into that because i think that
documentary
really has crystallized this argument
because a lot of these media
opportunities whether it's you at google
you know garth davis on the doctors
these things that are happening
are a result of that documentary which
is creating this this
debate and so in the wake like you were
i can just finish your sentence like in
the wake of
of the acclaim or the attention that
that documentary garnered
there was a backlash that that sort of
hit with quite a bit of
severity yeah there absolutely was and
you know
maybe some were offended by statements
in the movie but i think a lot of it was
the obligation
you're in a corner that says animal
products are healthy grass-fed is good
uh it's better for the environment
because animals pooping restores the f
the soil all kinds of crazy statements
and yeah there was one after another
whether it's dave asprey whether it's
nina taiko's whether it's the diet
doctor whether it's
um on and on david perlmutter they all
had a voice in and
you know the movie took some hits um
although they were largely inauthentic
and easily
answered as i did in a blog i wrote um
to some degree um i actually was pleased
to see just yesterday morning there was
a review of the movie i mean it's seven
months later why people are reviewing it
like it's a new movie very positive
um yeah but that that has done a lot to
raise the conversation and we can come
back to what the hell i just want to say
one of the
i think breakthroughs that your audience
i would imagine
doesn't know and a person that i would
put as one of the highlights in 2017
i call the new friend is right here in
los angeles you have at usc something
called the institute of biogerontology
a research institute about aging in fact
there's a word
juvenology the study of remaining
youthful juvenile youthful we should all
be juvenologists uh vegan juveniles
we probably are and that's all led by a
italian-born scientist
walter longo phd who came to the united
states at age 16 to be
a blues jazz guitarist from
genoa spoke no english but could
blow some riffs on his guitar in the
chicago bars
but by age 19 was fascinated that he
never saw disease in his family in italy
and he was living in chicago and his
relatives were getting sick and bloated
and he had the foresight he's 50 years
old now
uh so whatever it was 31 years ago to
say this nutrition stuff this aging
stuff
this is more meaningful than becoming a
jazz guitarist and he totally shifted
his career
went to texas and then went to l.a and
got a phd with some very famous
calorie restriction longevity experts at
ucla and then he set up his lab at usc
and anybody can go read about him he's
one of the most fascinating incredible
authentic nobel prize nominated
scientist last year at age 49
came in second it's called the jubilee
award because the same field he
concentrates on
was also being studied by some 90 year
old scientists in japan and
they gave it to the uh to the scientists
that you know had been in the field a
little longer he will win a nobel prize
but he has kind of risen to the light um
as a unbiased i think a spokesman for
clarity saying
you can't judge nutri he go number one
don't
outsource your nutrition to amateurs is
the example he gives if your neighbor's
an engineer an automobile engineer in
detroit
you're not going to go flying an
airplane they need design between
detroit and new york
i mean get a professional to build that
plane don't outsource your nutrition to
amateurs
and base any evaluation nutrition on
what he calls five pillars one pillar's
basic basic science which he is the
leading
world scientist on many of these aspects
what does
sugar in the diet do to basic pathways
and the answer is it's not very healthy
for us
what does animal protein do to basic
pathways the answer is it activates
aging and cancer promoting pathways
called mtor called pka ras
sertuan pathways he's he's a superb
scientist so you've got your basic
science you've got your
association studies epidemiology flawed
but you can't ignore them
you've got centenarian studies i mean if
you've got a diet ketogenic diet
let's find a population in the world
that's living to their 90s and 100 and
climbing mountaintops
and eats anything that could be called
approximating that the way it's being
described by these meat-eating
uh you know bloggers nutritious it
doesn't exist it does exist in okinawa
and other
places loma linda where we have many
examples that approximate the diet weed
i mean let's talk about randomized
studies which are pretty uncommon but
let's include those and there's a
fifth pillar i don't really remember
right now his book came out a week ago
and he concludes you know that in about
one paragraph
you can just slash away what is commonly
done in the paleo
and the low carb high fat ketogenic diet
as an extremely dangerous
age-accelerating high mortality eating
pattern
if done with animal products and if done
chronically
and he concludes we should all be eating
and he's not a member of our you know
traditional vegan community
he concludes we should be eating whole
food plant-based enjoy life have a
little wine if you want have a little
sugar if you want um he likes fish one
or two times a week he says in a very
broken english
or not so broken vegan fish i'm a vegan
fish eater um
and he grew up on the coast of genoa and
maybe it's a little bit of that
a little bit of science uh a lot of us
have concern
about fish and it's toxicity and fish
and it's the
population of the oceans and there's
arguments there
but you know knowing that this shining
light future
nobel laureate has parsed through this
and challenges this other side who don't
even know
that his argument is this profound five
pillar assessment
nutrition and really there's maybe five
people in the world can really say i've
done all these studies and this is my
conclusion dr longo is one of them
is i think just a tremendous
uh way that people so conflicted and
confused in the public can say i need
somebody to listen to so go read the
longevity diet by dr
longo after you read your new edition
and my book and uh
you won't be confused anymore yeah you
just showed me that book i gotta get
that guy on the podcast
i can help you with that he's um he's a
high energy
he still plays a mean mean jazz guitar
maybe you can get him to uh
to bring it here and have a little fun i
mean he lives by lax and uh
i i can work hard to set that up in fact
if you'll
interview him about his book i can
guarantee you it'll happen oh yeah
absolutely so
let me ask you this then and i don't
want to go two down can somebody who
eats fish two times a week be a guest on
your back yes
yeah okay of course coco i have an
opening
um what is it about eating meat
or animal protein specifically that
causes the aging like what is his thesis
on that or what is this yeah and you
know i'll go short so you can go
longo with longo um it's kind of funny
the world's leading expert in longevity
is named longo
of course you know dr toothacher yeah
right right right dr smelzy the foot
doctor
uh we have a urologist in detroit whose
name is
rod stiff and that could not be true it
would not be a better name for your eyes
it's really his name i trained with him
pity that guy growing up i think it's
your best calling card
um but there he didn't have a choice in
what he was going to become
yeah absolutely um so the basic tenet is
he he's used besides the word juvenology
the study of uh
anti-aging or staying youthful in life
staying useful in your brain and
activity
um in other words nutratech
nutratechnology that
um you can use food to activate pathways
that either lead to healing regeneration
rejuvenation
stem cell production or you can use food
that activates pathways so there's a
pathway called
mtor mammalian target of rapamycin
pretty sciency term
um rapamycin was from i think easter
island
rapua island and they found this fungus
that makes this molecule that
um has actually therapeutic benefit it's
used in transplant patients mtor
but you need um when you
um when you're growing you need your
growth hormone when you're a child you
need growth hormone there's a receptor
in cells for growth hormone
and when you eat animal-based protein
products
growth hormone is activated leads down
the path to maybe
something you've heard about igf-1
insulin like growth factor one
great thing when you're growing great
thing to maybe you're 18 or 20.
but eating animal products particularly
with
this amino acid leucine continue to
trigger the growth hormone down through
the
igf-1 pathway and you know we don't want
too much cell growth when you're 45 50
55 because we got these little cells
that are
uh waiting to transform into a line of
cancer
um and uh and
and leucine is in meat it doesn't matter
grass-fed doesn't matter if it's uh free
range
it's in meat much more you're going to
find it in beans and greens
sugar will activate other pathways uh
it's called the pka pathway so
diets and you know nobody in the health
field i think is a fan of sugar
and nobody espouses it that became a
debate about the what the health movie
uh certainly dr barnard and dr davis
were not advocating high sugar diets but
uh it's a different kind of topic about
sugar and the development of
type 2 diabetes um and then there are
some other so this
so you can create a diet low in sugar
low in um
uh animal-based amino acids like leucine
uh low in protein and what they've shown
in humans so
what dr longo did that's fascinating is
when he started his career about 25
years ago or so
they were studying a lot of mouse models
still pretty complex even though it's a
lot less
of a of a mammal than the human he went
backwards to yeast
single simple cell yeast and said this
will allow me a model to study
and nobody knew the word mtor or this
these terms i used
and he's the one that identified these
pathways that are now known to be
fundamental in aging healing
generation this field of juvenology and
it turns out the
reason that his science has been so uh
mind-blowing is
these pathways in a yeast are completely
preserved in the human species
so what he found in the single cell
organism is the same biochemistry that's
occurring in your my cell right now and
it has
profound dietary implications so he went
on
like i said these five pillars that was
some of the basic biochemistry
and i think it's october 1 2016 a study
was published in a major
journal jama internal medicine take six
000 free range adults
do very careful assessments high animal
protein eating free range adults have a
high mortality rate
low animal protein eating adults have a
low mortality rate that's a very
profound statement
those that eat a lot of vegetable based
protein didn't have that relationship
whether they were low or high they
had a survival advantage over the meat
eating group but
high protein diets accelerate aging
through these biochemical pathways
cell death our inability to clear
damaged cells out that's called
autophagy that won the nobel prize that
dr longo came in second on um vegetable
protein doesn't seem to activate it
there is in just to finish that
conversation
as adults get over age 65 or 70
protein becomes a more important
nutrient
to sustain their health long term so dr
longo and some other experts because you
lose muscle mass you don't want to be a
frail
a muscle depleted elderly person you'll
be very prone to ammonia infection and
other things falling breaking bones
so you want to emphasize and i would say
just emphasize vegetable protein your
whole life eat beans eat greens he nuts
eat seeds eat whole grains
because you're going to be in the sector
where this accelerated aging phenomenon
doesn't exist
so fancy stuff but it's led to and
that that nutrient technology that
nutrient sensing pathways
high animal protein activates his aging
through biochemistry it's well described
i don't know how many rabbit pests i can
go down there's there are these people
in ecuador
call um called the laurent israeli
scientist
v leron described these people 40 years
ago they had
their cells lack the receptor for growth
hormone
so their body their their brain produces
growth hormone their cells
can't respond to it so they're very
short people
because their cells are deficient in
growth hormone
they have unbelievably low igf-1 levels
their whole life
and there's nearly and now a scientist
in ecuador
amy guevaras and dr longo goes down to
ecuador now all the time
has described these people do not get
type 2 diabetes these people do not get
cancer
at a rate unbelievably less than the
general population of ecuador
so all these pathways is just another
piece of those five pillars
we can do that with food when we we can
eat a diet that is naturally
low in producing levels of igf-1 when we
eliminate dairy when
animal protein and emphasize the diet
you and i eat we're eating
a longevity diet which is exciting to
know and that the body of science is
profound on that
and it's totally totally missed by our
carn
carne eating carnivorous friends with
loud voices
yeah and just on an anecdotal level or a
population studies
type sociological survey of the
situation
it's pretty self-evident when you look
at the work that that dan buettner has
done with the black zones like you just
look at these cultures look at how
they're living look what they're eating
right look at their their social you
know structure
their social their community-based you
know way of life
and these are the people that are living
the longest they tend to be the people
that are the most
content and fulfilled in their lives and
it's almost to me like i don't i don't
need the inquiry to go
much further than that but it's good to
know that there are studies out there
that i've never heard about
the this ecuadorian population that's
fascinating
it really is and it's it's the layers of
support
for what you've chosen to do with your
life and your career and what i've
chosen to do with my cardiology practice
and career
is profoundly more established than the
general public believes
and i really do believe dr longo if that
voice is heard
is going to do a lot to clarify
i was with some business people in los
angeles this morning extremely
intelligent people in the
organic uh not food world but organic
world of uh consumer products
and they threw up their hands and they
said we're totally confused
guide us and you know and these are you
know so what the rank and file
doing with this issue either not paying
attention which i can understand there's
other issues in life when your paycheck
is
is an issue and or they're just uh
throwing their hands up like everybody
says
moderation everything i'll do what i
want which is a very dangerous
statement to make for health it seems to
me that this
current divide in philosophies around
diet nutrition etc can be tracked
back to uh the debate
that that occurred in the 70s between
sugar and fat and the kind of high carb
uh or not high carb uh high fat low carb
community will point to the sugar
industry as the culprit
who sort of conspired for lack of a
better term to point the finger at fat
as being you know the evil you know the
the evil contributor
to to poor health at the time which led
to
our 1970s you know low-fat craze
and this camp will say that that that
actually contributed to
our obesity epidemic when in fact
sugar was what we should have been
looking at all along so can you
say i have i have my own opinions on
this but can you share your perspective
on that yeah and i'll reference first of
all was that an accurate
um yeah i i i think we covered a little
bit of this and then we did
i think talk about dr ansel keys on the
last time
we chatted with you so we've sort of
been to i don't want to come out early
down there he was taken down his amazing
work was taken down and you were trying
to explain like right
so what we've learned since then rather
shockingly and i think it's it
appears to be real as three researchers
at harvard in 1965
wrote an article a two-part article in
new england journal medicine i've
actually tried to read the article
it's such dense science maybe
a thousand people in the world ever read
it this wasn't an article that you know
got headlines it was an article that
influenced um a lot of rank and file
people at all
but nonetheless uh some researchers
found some records that those three
researchers took
about five thousand dollars a piece from
the sugar industry which
might translate to fifty thousand
dollars nowadays in terms of uh
equivalent uh economic value to perhaps
bias the conclusion of this extremely
dense scientific article
um towards favoring anything other than
sugar being a health issue
for biochemistry of the human condition
one of them a guy named david hegested
was a
peer of ansel keys not a
co-researcher and was the head of the
nutrition department at harvard and you
know
shines poorly but has been exploded to
say
all research all researchers dr ansel
keys everybody involved with the
american heart association
everybody's in the same
situation as if everybody was a hashtag
me too
you know across the board every guy is
in the same boat i mean that's unfair
everybody gets to live their life and
judge and have authentic
uh hopefully uh careers and all so it's
been overblown
i think it's a very small drop in the
bucket of a larger issue
um again bringing it back to what we're
just talking about
i mean uh sugar as a
when this uh there is a statement as
anybody who's seen the documentary what
the health knows by dr neil barnard
sugar doesn't cause type 2 diabetes um
it's it's the fat and
garth davis gets in the topic so i had
to dig into that a bit and it's relevant
to what you just asked
because i'm just a humble cardiologist
advising patients putting in stents i'm
not an endocrinologist and
you know frankly i traveled to the
website of the american diabetes
association a little button there says
myths about type 2 diabetes we used to
call it adult diabetes but
kids are getting it now and the first
myth they expose sugar causes type 2
diabetes myth that's american diabetes
association that's what neil barnard
just said
went to the joslin diabetes center
website which is out of boston
same exact statement myth it's not the
case the
a the diabetic association of the uk
same exact response
so i actually you know felt that i
didn't have too much doubt that
neil answered appropriate based on the
science
but i called up a guy named gerald
shulman he's the head of endocrinology
at yale he's from detroit he speaks
at wayne state university the medical
school that i'm a faculty member of
quite often and i discussed this with
him and he said just to put it all
together
he goes calorie excess causes type 2
diabetes americans eat 800 calories a
day
more than they used to on average you
don't i don't i mean some people are
eating 1500 calories a day
more than they did in 1970. most of that
is processed food rich in
processed oils sugars refined grains
it's a whole gamut
if you actually designed a diet that you
ate so much excess sugar that you packed
on 25 30 pounds
you'd be very likely to develop insulin
resistance but
it could happen with other diets that
were just uh you know uh processed oil
and fat heavy
it's not specific there's nothing unique
about sugar that leads to type 2
diabetes it's
it's it's it's deterioration of the
american diet and
moving away from home-cooked meals
garden meals uh
the whole you know response we see so
um the sugar issue is overblown because
it's an easy target now i mean it's not
a nutrient that you need to eat it's not
to say that sugar is
when we're talking about sugar we're
talking about refined sugar we're not
talking about the sugar in an orange
right
or an apple but to be clear nobody's
saying sugar is a health food you
shouldn't be eating
refined sugar i mean glucose in your
bloodstream is an essential nutrient you
don't have glucose you will die
and we that sometimes gets confused
we're telling sugar and food
um you know a study came out in 2017
from china the first author
dao or do do you i think it is 600 000
chinese the more
whole fruit they ate the lower was a
risk of developing type 2 diabetes
those that had two type diabetes those
that ate the most fruit at the lowest
risk of complications of type 2 diabetes
dr longo seems a little bit shy on fruit
more vegetables less fruit couple three
servings a day
might be all that you choose to put in
your diet
i was interested in seeing that but yeah
um
nutrition is complex but sugar has
gotten backlash that is excessive um
and what's the message for you know can
you enjoy an occasional sweet and an
occasional um you know uh
deviant from the best that's probably
the only error i'd say moderation
occasionally is not going to be very
harmful with sugar i'd rather you be
i'd rather be more meticulous about
added fats of animal origin
processed oils not whole foods we all
agree we all love avocados we all love
nuts we love olives
uh really without exception i think on
top of that
uh the idea that the low-fat
craze contributed to the obesity
epidemic
is reductionist and
patently false in the sense that it
presumes
that people actually ended up eating
low-fat diets as a result of that
kind of edict coming down from on high
which is actually not what people were
doing
there was a proliferation of low-fat and
fat-free
foods but that doesn't mean that overall
if you broke down somebody's daily
caloric intake that it ended up being
low-fat because
this meets the ascension of the
processed food
landing on the shelves at the grocery
stores and
a lot of those foods were
you know the foods that we ended up
binging on yeah absolutely i mean
um i agree with you 100 uh dr dean
ornish presents data that if you go to
the usda and look what happened since
about 1970 and on even those advised eat
a low-fat diet to protect your heart
americans didn't listen the amount of
fat in the diet went up
as did calories as did refined foods as
did sugar we simply ate more of
everything
the abundance of restaurants and no
longer cooking at home and
convenience of grocery stores where the
middle are packed with
grab-and-go kind of items we we shifted
our diet in an adverse way
there are people that are sugar addicted
and just like every other food addiction
it's real and are probably best to have
extreme
care and avoiding added sugars and
they're hidden in everything barbecue
sauce and dressings and
57 names for sugar that the food
industry is allowed to use
fructose and corn syrup and maltodextrin
and for those that find that eating
foods and sugar
are just not resonating with their diet
i own two restaurants
i've had dessert in my restaurants maybe
three times in two and a quarter years
i just don't go there i'm not addicted
but i know it's not
you know on my food plate is a very com
you know it's not the health
group that i'm gonna do very often and
i'm there every night or many nights
um i i want to point out one of the
maybe you can get
uh penn gillette on your uh on your
podcast of penn
teller but he i just finished his book
well i'll tell you the connection you
you
your your neighbor in calabasas juliana
hoever can get him to you just had her
and rayon recently i mean i didn't uh i
haven't
put that episode up okay yeah because i
think ray ray cronize is one of the most
fascinating food thinkers out there now
and
so yeah so penn gillette in the book
presto so i don't know
that that book hasn't really hit a lot
of people's uh nightstand
i hid mine recently and one it's one of
the funniest books you'll ever read he's
outrageous in these
his languages his his laying his chapter
on
ask me about protein which has more
f-bombs did you read the book yeah i
read that chapter yeah oh my god is that
funny but the whole book's like that
and he has a chapter on joel fuhrman and
i just was with joel fuhrman in detroit
last couple days he didn't know there
was a whole chapter on him in
even though in some ways it's very very
respectful and praiseworthy
of the book he to live in joel fuhrman
it's penn's nature to make fun of people
and change names so uh
i tell you he's ordering the book to
read it but that experience of a
sugar addicted human who had to follow
an extreme but also extremely um
effective you know ultimate high complex
carb
sugar-free diet also oil-free diet
i mean that's necessary for some people
that are battling you know the 130 extra
pounds that
he was carrying around that was going to
kill him and others so yeah the sugar
story has been overblown except i wanted
to be sensitive to people
that really do feel that their
physiology is affected and their
psyche is affected so just stay away eat
fruit and nothing more or don't eat
fruit
you can survive without fruit let's talk
about heart disease you are a
cardiologist
thank you we should talk about your
expertise well
we're preventing our discussion we just
had is about preventing heart disease we
didn't call it
the global sense in global sense of
course so are we still in a situation
where
the statistics dictate that one out of
every three people
will die of heart disease yeah you know
there's
there's good and bad news the last few
weeks the
survival of the average u.s citizen went
down for the second year in a row now a
very small amount
opioid addiction opioid deaths got a lot
of the
headline for it but it's rather
distressing with all the progress and
what i've seen in my 30-year medical
career um
and and devices and procedures and all
that overall lifespan is going down and
you know we live in a very very tough
time but that's a bad news
cardiovascular disease actually seemed
to be a little bit better than the year
before
it's still number one canada's switched
canada cancer's number one
cardiovascular disease number two
we're we're close but i don't see it uh
shying away and yes the cardiologists in
me and i was hoping we'd get there i
always want to talk about
how you can identify silent heart
disease so you don't become the
statistic i'm trying to think of the
last
celebrity i keep talking about blake
krikorian a
very famous investor in l.a he was
walking from the beach to his car with a
surfboard under his arm about a year ago
and
age 48 worth 500 million dollars dropped
out of an acute heart attack i mean
you know i i i feel less bad about the
business aspect he had a bunch of little
kids
uh you know tragedies where there's
young children left without
usually a father it could be a mother
it's just the way the disease goes in
your 40s
i want everybody to listen to this quote
paul dudley white
was the cardiologist to md taking care
of president eisenhower in the 50s and
he said
emphatically a heart attack after age 80
is
a act of god a heart attack before age
80 is a failure of the medical system
he said that in 1955 that we already
know
the majority of the science what causes
heart attacks he had no idea about the
technology
we have nowadays to identify heart
disease early but man
a heart attack before age 80 is a
failure medical system we've had a
completely unsuccessful medical system
i can in the next three minutes tell
everybody who's listening how to
change that outlook for their own health
which is critical
yeah and we're going to get into that
and just as a as a way of launching into
that i had
our mutual friend kim williams on the
podcast a little while back
wonderful and yeah what an amazing human
being that guy is
right and you know one of the things he
said that i'm sure you will agree with
is that there have been these amazing
dramatic
um leaps and bounds in the science and
technology of
how we treat heart disease in the form
of stents and medications and surgical
procedures
and the like that have reduced the
mortality rate
of people who suffer from this disease
but at the same time
a blind eye being turned to the actual
root cause and how to
prevent people from actually getting to
the situation where
they need all of this absolutely true
which is why
our initial conversation is what dr dean
ornish and even before him uh
dr burkett dennis burkett a british
physician who
uh did amazing nutrition work in africa
talked about the faucet that you know if
you walked into your bathroom and the
sink was overflowing
you wouldn't run out and go get mops and
towels and
address the problem that way you go turn
the sink off and deal with the root
issue that the sink's overflowing
because somebody left the faucet on
the medical system is a mop and towel
kind of system you've had your heart
attack what amazing technology
well what about the wendy's in the lobby
of the hospital like the hospital i
practice at harper university hospital
that's a faucet what about wendy's still
there it's still there and i've been so
successful with my social media campaign
they put a chick-fil-a this year next to
it and and and i'll give a shout out
tonight
i'm laughing beaumont hospital in royal
oak michigan just contracted with mark
wahlberg
to put in a wahlburgers at our medical
complex which is
no better than wendy's although it's got
mark's q's face and a lot of the posters
um you know when you get
government-issued cheese which is
basically velveeta
and you're serving that to the nurses
walking over from the hospital to
the strip mall it's it's outrageous so
um off the beaten path so that's how you
turn off the faucet is
everything we talked about but the
technology the faucet isn't the same
faucet we've got better technology
upstream it's always upstream we can um
let's talk for a minute maybe
you know you've got your notes but i
want to talk about like bob harper
and what he went through real quick and
you know how do you prevent bob harper
if he doesn't mind me using him as an
example biggest loser fitness trainer
age 51 ripped guy in the past
always with a green juice in his hand
and all and working out at the gym
february 2017 drops dead he has a
cardiac arrest on the treadmill
by the grace of heaven above next to him
on the treadmill was a cardiologist and
on the wall in front of him was an
external defibrillator
and within about the shortest time any
human could have he's got a trained
professional on top of him with the pads
that say shock and he came back to life
rushed to the hospital
i believe he had a stint i haven't
actually read that and he was on the
ventilator but he's just one lucky dude
brain kidneys everything kind of came
back
and he went on the oz show march or
april 2017
and said the obvious question how could
you have had a heart attack with all
your workouts and muscles and all those
years on the biggest lose or so with jd
roth and
your buddy and all that um and he said i
found out i have a genetic kind of
cholesterol nobody ever checked called
lipoprotein
a it's a if you whatever doctor you're
seeing the routine cholesterol panel
doesn't include that
lpa sticky cholesterol lipoprotein a
there are three terms for the same
molecule
costs about 25 dollars to run the blood
test normal levels in most labs less
than 30.
i have dozens of patients whose blood
levels are 300 400
500 and it just erodes their arteries
and ages their vascular system and it
will never show up in a routine physical
unless you read you know the new york
times recently talking about bob harper
blogs i've written thank you bob harper
for bringing up the issue there is a
lipoprotein a foundation
how common is it 63 million americans
have elevated lipoprotein a levels 20
of adults it's genetic so you can eat
well that's the
kicker you you're bob harper you're rich
role you're joel khan you got plants you
work out you do yoga
you got love and happiness in your heart
and you got a lipoprotein a level of
400 you still can suffer stroke and
heart attack
um so that's one way i don't even know
like i don't even have myself you
haven't had it yeah and you know and
i'm 51. yeah and i can you know write
you out a blood slip but so can any
doctor you know do it you can go to
cedar you can go anywhere
it's a simple test you don't have to go
to any exotic lab um that's
upstream that's turning off the faucet
because if you're elevated
the typical response right now is make
sure the rest of your lifestyle is
perfect because you've got a genetic
risk
that can't be dealt with be sure you eat
well be sure you
meditate be sure your blood pressure
cholesterol blood sugar
inflammation markers like c-reactive
protein make sure everything else is
spot-on and that's all
valid and important and i think that's
the path that bob harper talks about on
social media since then
um there is a drug investigation statins
don't lower lipoprotein a
so take them off the uh list for that
things like lipitor
there is pretty strong data that niacin
a b vitamin used at high doses lowers
lipoprotein a that's one approach i use
in my own clinic my own patients
and i can see their levels come down
dramatically the science hasn't yet
designed a proper study to say that's
going to mean somebody's going to be
less likely
to have a heart attack stroke and live
longer because nobody funds a study
with a drug like niacin that over the
counter in a drugstore costs pennies
yeah you can't make any money you can't
make any money so just to be clear
though if you
if you have this lipoprotein a lifestyle
diet i'm sure it has some you know has a
benefit on your overall health but that
is not going to be
a uh it won't protect you from that
single
uh there's there's a supplement company
i like that has this dramatic
uh poster of the heart and 19 daggers
pointing at the heart of which
blood pressure cholesterol blood sugar
ldl h tail but
lipoprotein a is one of those daggers so
it won't protect you from that one
dagger may
you know ameliorate and turn the faucet
or slow the faucet from
you know 7 or 10 or 12 of the 19 but
homocysteine is
a blood test an amino acid genetically
kind of monitored that you should know
and you should check these things cost
pennies or a few dollars and
many of them like lipoprotein a you do
it once you're 400 you got a problem
you're four you have no problem and you
won't have a problem because it's
genetic
so that's why i mean that's so how we
doing i don't in my 30 years
we have cooler stents we can put in
heart valves
without cracking the chest more and more
some places do robotic bypass but we're
still filling
coronary care in its emergency rooms and
operating rooms
with procedures that you know from 1990
we know
could be prevented 50 60 70 80 percent
of the time using dean ornish data and
dr esselstyn data but
it's frustrating that um we're seeing
that
being grabbed on to by medical students
i'm very encouraged by medical students
they
are the future so if we wait a
generation we may actually get
a lot of plant friendly or plant-only
doctors in the communities
but it's pretty rare right now so just
to follow this theme
another way to turn that faucet off of
people
dropping and requiring acute cardiac
care
is the specialty that kim williams is an
expert at there are these cat scans of
the heart i'm passionate about this
topic
you're 51 you should have one uh you
don't look 51. i mean
that's actually yeah no i've been
thinking you know just even then so
thinking of you coming over i was like
you know i should really get one yeah
so there's a great documentary called
the widowmaker and everybody can watch
it on netflix after they watch what the
health
at ucsf they designed a cat scan
20 years ago and perfected it it doesn't
exist anymore because every standard cat
scanner does this now
you lie down on a gurney you go in the
machine you hold your breath for 10
seconds you go home
there's no iv there's no iodine there's
a very small amount of radiation from
the cat scan equivalent to like a
mammogram that a woman has
and you get a number are my heart
arteries calcified zero
is the winning number i wrote a blog
called the biggest celebration of the
heart
calcium score zero because it is that
your chance in the next 10 years having
a heart attack
and in fact the data goes you're it's a
sign of aging of the body not just heart
arteries your chance having kidney
problems cancer
brain diseases are extremely low because
you have a youthful biochemistry things
are working out for you
and it's a very complex process to
really judge what's your real age i mean
you're 51 i'm 58 but internally
are we are we 10 years younger than that
are we 10 years older
calcium score is a measure of true aging
of our system and certainly our arteries
and if your calcium score is as i have
patients 1400 1600 1100
these are very very very degraded
arteries
with a process that needs to be
investigated rarely leads to need for
bypass need for stent
but is the ability to wrap around
all kinds of lifestyle and even more
than lifestyle if needed measures
so this calcium score in my city cost 70
who doesn't need it you've had a bypass
you've had a stent you've had a heart
attack you know the answer to the
question
do you have heart disease you're off the
table i don't even think
in my practice the ultra healthy um
should avoid it because
uh it's such a count those 19 daggers
have you had all of them measured and
assessed
not you personally but the public in
general no so
i don't care where people are listening
with chitau kansas and
gainesville florida you can get a
c-a-c-s
corona artery calcium scan no iodine
in indiana south bend is 45 you don't
need a prescription
my state you need a prescription from a
doctor and i literally hand these
prescriptions out when i give a talk
people hear it
i'll write them a script because i mean
it's it's a service
for them to either be reassured that
they're
doing great and i have patients with a
cholesterol 300 calcium score is zero
and the stress you take off of them doc
so i can get off the prescription drug
and really really focus on lifestyle for
three months or six months and
try and whip this thing but i don't how
could you have a a
an elevated there's 19 daggers and
uh cholesterol has never been the only
one and it's always
they're more complicated than we want
them to be no it's really pretty simple
nobody's ever said cholesterol is the
only risk factor for heart disease i
mean the american heart association
picked
five back in the 60s smoking diabetes
family history blood pressure
cholesterol in age kind of factors
it's always been you know a complex
predictive calculation but this cat scan
cuts through all that
and says let's get real let's you know
take 70
take you know literally a minute and
don't risk it
if you're the 10 of americans that have
extremely high
silent heart disease you know how
i mean is this somebody that's people is
this something that people who are like
in their twenties should do like should
everybody
get quite a certain age where this
becomes more relevant i've
rarely personally i've ordered thousands
and thousands and thousands and
thousands of these studies over the
years because it's been available
in detroit in every major city for 15
years and now even medium-sized cities
usually at a hospital doctors don't own
cat scanners hospitals have cat scanners
so i make no money you know this is not
an economic thing this is a plea to turn
the faucet off
upstream um rarely i mean if i had a 28
year old and his cluster was 600 there
are a few
you know i might find a reason to do
this if they're ekg or something
usually it's a test for somebody 40 and
up
50 if you're you know great lifestyle 40
a whole lot of people have heart attacks
in their early 40s that
almost always the presence of disease
could have been identified
the reason you don't hear about it much
is not availability it's not cost
it's not science 2 000 scientific
studies and again dr kim williams is an
expert in the field of
cat scanning of the heart it's that the
ultimate study
let's take 5 000 people everybody get a
cat scan
half will get the results and get a
program to try and work on it half will
not get the results and
let's see if it makes a difference in
terms of death or heart attack
that kind of study hasn't been done but
every study that says let's look at
cholesterol or blood pressure or
any other measure other than this cat
scan the cat scan wins the day as being
by far the most accurate which is
intuitive because you're actually
looking at the heart directly not
indirectly so
yeah there is some data you've got a lot
of uh
high level athletes and i'm sure
listening
um that actually multiple endurance
athletic events may actually accelerate
calcification and heart arteries it's
very confusing i know you've written a
little bit about this yeah it's like i'm
all
i'm almost afraid to read those articles
because
you know i'm looking we need you around
news we know that you know exercise
please exercise we know that people that
runners live longer than the average
american runners-up machine
remember jim fix well jim fix ate like a
pig he was 52.
yeah he was very famous for saying i can
eat whatever i want because i
exercise so much i don't know if he had
lipoprotein a or just a bad diet or a
high cholesterol or homocysteine
but he had severe advanced three vessel
coronary disease at death tragic tragic
tragic and then
i use that example and now you the other
one is winston churchill fats
smoked cigars and he doesn't die of
heart attack and lives till 92.
so if you rely on sensible calculators
we screw up terribly the cat scan cuts
through all that nonsense
the good news about athletes is they are
lean they have better blood pressure
they tend to have better cholesterol
they tend to have better blood sugar
but whether ultra endurance exercise is
inflammatory
whether sometimes the diet isn't as
green and clean as yours
and how many athletic events end with
donuts and pizza
and uh and things that uh celebrate the
uh the survival of the event but don't
really uh
uh heal the body um so it's just it's
it's it opens a can of worm to be tested
and
one has to just like any almost genetic
testing you have to be resilient and say
i'll deal with the data and find the
best
uh course to take with it but um better
to know than not no
in the context of in the athlete example
is
so there's the there's calcification and
that's a result of
constantly uh submitting your body to
so much exercise induced stress that it
creates
kind of a chronic inflammation problem
where you're you're always dealing with
trying to recover from these workouts or
what is it specifically that is
leading to this conclusion well i don't
know that the answer is known why
are there now probably three dozen
studies easily
of analysis of heart arteries in
ultra athletes and calcification being
the easiest thing to measure
and it being uh elevated beyond
expectation even sometimes elevated
beyond people exercising less or not
exercising which is
rather distressing data don't stop
exercising no he's like i'm am i going
to
stop running now like maybe go back to
eating burgers and fries i mean yeah
because exercise is another topic is
there a sweet spot
is is exercise of moderation and
everything for the public not for
you know the really trained athlete not
for the professional athlete not for the
one who's passionate but
is the message to the public moderation
and exercise that um
you know i tell people do 10 minutes as
opposed to zero
because the feeling is if i don't get 60
minutes and it's not worthwhile 10
minutes is worthwhile but back to the
issue
you're probably not chronically inflamed
you're probably acutely inflamed
multiple studies say at the end of a
marathon if you draw blood
on a person presumably healthy a lot of
them will show
the enzyme that comes from the heart
that leaks during heart attacks
will be present in the bloodstream of
healthy people after a marathon called
troponin and in indeed it's stressful
um uh is it they were nutritionally
depleted as they didn't train adequately
and there's some data that those that
train more that's less common
if you do an mri or an echo of the heart
right after a marathon and a lot of
these have been done that way
actually the right side of the heart's
actually a bit dilated and not looking
so healthy 24 hours later it looks like
it recovered real well
but the question is if you do it
repeatedly and repeatedly and repeatedly
are you uh laying on layers of scar i
mean it's so it's not crowning you
probably
uh are not chronically inflamed uh
you're intermittently inflamed
from um you know a high level of sustain
and we're talking you know the kind of
stuff frankly that you do and your
friends do
not an hour at the gym um it's not
but the date is very murky that that
still
you know let's go to blue zones i mean
of course there's not too many ultra
athletes in blue zones and there is
some sense they're just like perpetual
motion but in terms of longevity
um and i'd love you to ask dr longo that
question when
you get them on but um there's no reason
to worry people that you're shortening
your lifespan you may be calcifying your
heart arteries
but and it may be a bit of an aging
process i mean i think you'd probably
agree some of what you do
is putting your body under stress and
the ultimate
of course of it all but uh you know i'm
going on record it's great to exercise
but don't just because you're a high
level athlete
not know your label protein and not know
your homocysteine not know your
c-reactive protein
inflammation and don't not spend 70 and
get a heart ct scan
recognizing you're going to need to dig
in and get a little research about
what do you do with it if it's abnormal
it's it's what i do every day but
it's not clear-cut i try and basic on
science but just like nutrition
maybe we got three pillars not five
pillars but do the best we can
let's talk about saturated fat okay i
feel like i have this conversation every
time i have a doctor on this show uh
and i'm still trying to get clear on
this
i know your perspective right and then i
look at
um you know asim
mel hortas how do you say his last name
who i've met and seems like a nice guy
he's
bright guy and he'll say saturn we now
know
saturated fat has no impact on dietary
cholesterol in essence he's saying
all this worry about saturated fat is
misplaced this is not something you need
to concern yourself with respect to
cardiovascular disease right
true or false false false dangerous
um distorted
um and instantly gets an
international media attention which uh
he's very good at
um and that in and of itself may be no
accident it may be
part of the food industry and and such
that
you know get a cardiologist to write in
a journal or do a
talk about animal based foods and
saturated fat in animal and based foods
you know being maligned and actually
being healthy will
you know support a whole lot of
industries that are suffering right now
which is great i hope they're suffering
and and wither up but um it's a popular
thing
so again not going there but ansel keys
and many other researchers because he oh
he himself always had
17 18 other co-researchers of tremendous
fame that never took money from the
sugar field so
his co-workers that are still many of
them alive in
italy and henry blackburn who's dan
buettner's neighbor
at age 93 in minneapolis one of the most
amazing scientists and such many of them
are alive
parsed out very clearly in all kinds of
again like five pillars basic science
and
epidemiology and all animal-based
saturated fat promotes a high blood
cholesterol which
is associated with and would be
reasonable to say causes atherosclerosis
hardening the arteries
limit your animal saturated fat ansel
key's diet was very rich in
olive oils it wasn't a what it's build a
low-fat diet
his cookbooks are clearly not low-fat
diets they're not vegan diets
um but they were low in they never
included coconut oil it's not a
mediterranean diet
food and ancel keys described to america
the mediterranean diet that
most of us agree is a reasonable place
to sit in the middle if you got to sit
somewhere
but then came along 2008 if you
talked to um a scientist on blanket on
his name for a minute
but exposed by michael greger and one of
his nutrition facts
dot org youtube's there was a meeting in
mexico city in 2008 the dairy industry
saying
you know we're losing the battle people
are drinking less dairy we need to find
sympathetic scientists we need to find
sympathetic
bloggers we need to presumably support
them
invite them to meetings fund their
travel and we need to put
dairy for sure back on the map within a
few months
a scientist in oakland california ronald
krauss md
runs a big pediatric lipid lab
in oakland is talking to the national
dairy council and giving
keynote talks that he's being paid for
on the other
the health aspects of saturated fat if
specifically dairy
which is typically rich in saturated fat
and then 2010 comes a
meta-analysis review by a patty
siri torino and who's the last author
ronald krauss who
john mcdougall calls dr lard he doesn't
respect
dr krauss much as a scientist and feels
since almost every paper
he writes is funded by the dairy
association and all
comes his 2010 article and then that
questions we
can't verify that saturated fat is
associated with increased risk heart
disease it's a
meta-analysis it's not new science it's
just a way to play with
existing studies um i'd a study that was
so
bad that the journal it was published in
published right with it a complete and
utter
uh disembowelment and critique which is
very rare people write letter to the
editors to the journal afterwards but
here's the science here's jeremiah
stamler a very esteemed
uh epidemiologist scientist who just
dissected the study they accepted it but
then they
really allowed a extreme criticism but
that all gets lost so we've got this
paper
there's this you know that's and then
2014 another paper of a similar
bent uh by an author named chowdhury
that's
really the bedrock of this idea that we
have it all wrong and saturated fat is
okay they're both meta-analyses
kind of a weaker style of science it's
not original data
the meta-analysis by chowdhury was so
bad that the chief of the department of
public health at harvard walter willett
md one of the most respected scientists
called for it to be retracted but it
doesn't matter it's you know the
feathers and
how long ago was this 2010-2014 so
there's butter on the cover
right so this is what precipitated the
butter on the cover and between 2010
all kinds of hullabaloo um and malhotra
that's all he's got
i mean he doesn't have any new data that
says when dean ornish took a w
actually you can go way back when nathan
pritikin even before nathan pritikin a
internist in los angeles lester morrison
at cedars
took away saturated fat from his heart
patients found they lived 50 percent
longer in 1949-5051
nathan pritikin 70s 60s 80s showed that
his heart patients did dramatically well
there's no new data that says that's
wrong and we can now feed heart patients
coconut oil and butter and lamb and
turkey and
even fish which it can be high in
saturated fat there's no new data that
says that
there's these two confusing studies and
you know some ancillary ones
if you really go back to what's been
since 2014
this definitive series of association
studies from the harvard school of
public health that have confirmed
without doubt
when you are eating butter lard and ghee
your risk of cardiovascular disease is
high when you replace it with olive oil
it goes down about nine percent
when you replace it with vegetable oils
it goes down about 23
now they didn't go to the next step what
about if you have a diet that is
absent added vegetable oils because that
was
uncommon in these and these were a data
set of over 100 000 people followed for
more than 30 years
yes it has flaws and there's
occasionally a harvard researcher that
takes some money from
unilever that makes one of the vegetable
oils i mean it's hard to find scientists
that are lily white in terms of some
funding of research
but nonetheless you know why
that message still remains so confusing
truly the biochemistry of fats confuses
me the biology of fats you know
gotta sit down we gotta we gotta
separate set trans fat everybody hates
then we gotta
understand what are saturated fats well
some plants have saturated
fats like avocados olives olive oils 15
saturated fat and certainly coconut oil
is 82
saturated fat and so that's difficult
then we got to get to the
polyunsaturated fats and separate the
you know the the mufa the
monounsaturated fat like olive oil and
the pufas that are
omega-6 and omega-3 which this stuff is
just even it's so
confusing that literally i got to sit
down and write it all out and keep
repeating it over and over
what does the public do and then there
are still
room to discuss is olive oil on the
health menu or not dr david cat said
yale absolutely
walter longo of italian origin
absolutely we've got the cardiovascular
data we've got you know other um
authentic and
uh caring scientists that would say in
an obese society
you don't need you know 120 calories per
tablespoon of olive oil when you can do
it with
water vegetable stock or just steam
foods and save yourself some of this
calorie excess so
i'm still on board clearly my message my
patients
is avoid or
completely eliminate saturated fat
uh containing foods which are animal
foods largely and coconut and palm from
your diet
on the this issue of the complexity of
all of these oils and how they all work
polyunsaturated monounsaturated even in
the the saturated fat world we have
loric we have myristic we have palmitic
we have
steric like are there differences
between those
four different types of saturated
fats it's the length of the chain
16s and 18. the longer chains are much
more pro-ethanogenic so palmitic always
loses
palmitic acid is the most
pro-atherogenic it's
i'm not sure if it's 16 or 18 of the
long-chain fatty acids where stearic
which is one that does exist in
chocolate and is in some beef and used
by pro-beef people to say beef
which has a combination of fatty acids
uh it may
not be as bad but you know and lauric is
the one in in
coconut oil because you know coconut oil
that's what the mct
medium chain they're not long chains the
ideal
chain length is 12 carbon um
in coconut oil in terms of maybe being
neutral to atherosclerosis and that we
don't know for sure
but the problem is you go buy coconut
oil at the store i guarantee you it's
not going to tell you
it's a 100 12 carbon length or 14 or 16.
these are mixtures you're taking a risk
when you're buying it an
organic label isn't the issue it's it's
the mixture
in there there's no doubt people eating
a large amount of coconut oil raise
their blood cholesterol and raised blood
cholesterol is going to
favor the development of atherosclerosis
if your calcium scores zero
and your homocysteine lipoprotein a and
cholesterol is ideal
you want to put a little uh coconut oil
in your diet go for it but the problem
is people are doing it with
either known heart disease known
diabetes known obesity
or more commonly unknown
risk and they're they're taking a risk
so what is the history
or the story behind how coconut oil
became
considered to be this health elixir this
panacea
yeah it's um there actually is a book
in the 90s the miracle of coconut oil
and it's written by a naturopathic doc
although he doesn't put his degree there
indeed
the book he wrote before that is how to
take balloons and fold them into animal
shapes
so he's written a whole bunch of
interesting books it's really a true
story if you
were to go to amazon and go to like the
earliest coconut oil
short book and go just one before it by
the same author
so uh i don't know the man and if he's
still around and i'm not making fun of
him because i don't know his history but
it wasn't the chief of public health at
harvard school of public health
and there really is and we don't have a
definitive study
that says for most people who are trying
to avoid heart disease and aging
it's a healthful unhealthful food we
know that it raises cholesterol we know
it's not part of blue zones we know that
it's not part of the mediterranean diet
even though dr
malhotra introduces coconut oil to his
version which is
uh nothing other than another atkins
version it's not a mediterranean diet
um and that all crystallized june 25th
2017 when the president and the american
heart association
well that's another story ended up
having a heart attack in december at age
52 as the chairman of the ameri
president american heart association
john warner from dallas
but when he called a group of 11
scientists to say we need
an updated conversation on saturated fat
in the diet
that's called the presidential advisory
it was published in june 2017
they talked at length about this
spectrum of
eating butter lard ghee is your mainstay
of
fats in the diet what's the impact of
converting and i went through that data
and 25 page document 250 references
all of that was discussing and
concluding reducing saturated fat in the
diet is still the proper
conversation by a cardiologist with
their patients one paragraph out of 25
pages said
we have to conclude that the absence of
data that
coconut oil in a diet is helpful for
heart patients leads us to recommend
don't
include it in the diet and that's what
the
blogosphere the ketosphere the
you know the paleosphere when bananas
about to the point
dr mahatra agreed with the statement
that american heart was a terrorist
organization worse than isis
giving bad advice to the american public
and then our friend mark hyman
chimed in on that and agree with that
and it offended me chris chris
people were sharing this meme that the
american heart association was a
terrorist organization over the coconut
it's a scientifically valid statement to
say we don't have a definitive answer
you can argue does that mean that you
should avoid
a food that's very high in saturated fat
till science fills the void that's what
the american heart
i think authentically was arguing um it
was a pretty august
group of scientists from harvard from
northwestern from tufts some of the best
nutrition schools in
america and they didn't seem very
conflicted in the
uh long and detailed conflict of
interest uh
page that was at the end of the article
i think it's a reasonable conclusion but
god did ignite um a very conflicted
very inauthentic response
to the larger issue in the paper which
never got really discussed which is
go back to eating less meat go back to
eating less
animal products and find those amazing
substitutes that are
showing up everywhere in grocery stores
which are naturally going to lower your
saturated fat intake which
remains as valid as a statement today as
it did in 1970
when ansel keyes published a seven
country study um
with his co-authors is there any
evidence to support that somehow the
american heart association was
conflicted or corrupted somehow like
the the vietnam of the response was so
what you saw and what the health is real
they're not i mean
two dr kim williams credit and the
american college of cardiology they
weren't in that movie because they've
avoided some of the funding and the
conflicts and the recipes
the american heart association has a
little different mission public
education and nursing education cpr
but those recipes are on their website
and i've been to american heart
association meetings in the coca-cola
health tent and
you know you need to fund these
organizations and
you know there weren't companies around
like memphis meat and beyond meat and
uh um the mayo company and the
impossible burger and such you know
they need funding but they've
compromised their integrity and they've
lost
a little sticker on fruit loops that
says it's a whole grain cereal with
america i mean
they've lost a lot of credibility doing
that um
doesn't mean the scientists have lost
their credibility uh
and that's hard sometimes for the public
to distinguish
or it's easy let me say it's easy for
the bloggers to attack
and just throw everybody under the bus
it's pretty hard to throw
walter willett under the bus university
of michigan grad
emphasize well the the blogosphere has
been
loud and unequivocal in its
in its criticism of and its takedowns of
ansel keys
we went into that in length yeah in the
uh this first i think it was the second
time we did the podcast so i don't want
to rehash that and also
dean ornish you've also written about
that extensively and i believe we talked
about that
uh but maybe we could talk and and the
china study
but maybe we could talk about what the
health because that's sort of top of
mind for a lot of people a lot of people
have just seen it they're in the new
year maybe a lot of people are seeing it
for the first time
uh and you know i think the hot button
issues that that
that people found to be alarmist were
some of the more
some of the more controversial aspects
of the movie were the kind of visual
imagery that surrounded the processed
meats by putting like you know
cigarette or cigar in a hot in a hot dog
bun
and this link between processed meats
and uh and cancer
equivocating to what was it uh i can't
remember exactly five cigarettes a day
to eating one hot dog or something or a
pizza yeah it was one
one egg a day equals five cigarettes for
cardiovascular risk and then the process
meet cancer risk so
um yo people got pretty excited about
pretty excited and
i don't know kip anderson well we've
become acquainted
in 2017. it's not the first round he's
made of a movie his website has lots of
references
it's a documentary but i think it was a
very accurate and highly done
documentary so whether you like it or
not dr david jenkins md a very prominent
research scientist in toronto
published a study in 2012 of over a
thousand people
tracking how much plaque they had within
their carotid and how many eggs they ate
and he created kind of an index
how many eggs per week per year
and there was a relationship an
association
egg years and carotid thickening an
artery that's to your brain that you'd
like to keep youthful and all
and when he equated it in the same data
set to
those that responded they smoked and how
did those two risks associate
one egg equaled five cigarettes a day
and there was a statistical published
peer-reviewed not plant-based not
non-plant-based it was scientific data
like all association studies it raises
questions it's hypothesis generating
but it doesn't mean for kip to put it in
the movie was inappropriate or
scientifically fraudulent it's indeed
the data and
with the huge number of nutrition
studies funded by the egg board it's
pretty darn hard to find a credible
egg study in the last 10 or 15 years
there were a lot of them
20 years ago but the egg board really
started funding these studies
since then a lot of conflicted studies
the
processed meat goes back maybe your
listeners remember october 2015 world
health organization
after years of studies suggesting
processed meat was linked to
a rise in the risk of cancer and other
syndromes heart disease
congestive heart failure very strong
risk maybe number one in the diet if you
don't want to develop type 2 diabetes
cut out processed meats with a hot dog
bologna salami
pepperoni bacon but that was
crystallized when the world health
organization put out a
paper we reviewed 800 studies we have 22
world experts
we're not a vegan we're not this isn't
you know the plant-based movement
this i can't cast probably nobody knew
really the scientists they're just
authentic nutrition scientists
conclusion you know uh processed red
meats are class one carcinogens
not suspected but proven to cause cancer
particularly colorectal cancer
extended the prostate extended the
pancreatic extended to breast cancer but
statistics were highest because that
processed meat is sitting in the colon
so
presumably it's the organ most exposed
to risk since then the world health
organization has published follow-up
studies that confirm
without a doubt this was a valid
conclusion
there are more people die every year
worldwide of smoking
and cancer-related diseases and there
are the diet processed meats
maybe 50 000 people a year worldwide die
of processed meats and cancer
do we ignore that do we say that that's
not as many as
you know a million so we don't address
the issue right there was a
the issue was that it was hyperbolic in
the sense that the increase in
susceptibility was
relatively statistically minor but two
yeah two strips
less than two strips of bacon a day it's
50 grams raises
in a relative value your risk of
developing colorectal cancer by 18
now that may be from five percent to six
percent in the general public
that in itself may not sound impressive
i like my bacon so much i'll take a six
percent risk
not a five percent risk but it is
statistically valid
and uh the the wealth of data but nobody
will
extend the conversation let's talk about
heart disease erectile dysfunction
type 2 diabetes obesity dementia and
congestive heart failure another cardiac
syndrome i care a lot about
so what's the immediate step i mean
hospitals this
this has to be out of hospitals has any
hospitals since the world health
organization banned
processed meats none that i know of the
cleveland clinic was going to but i
think they've
capitulated what do you do in your own
life
you know eat less eat none that's for
each individual to decide and
any time you eat a food like that if you
do couple it with an antioxidant fiber
rich choice like
green leafies fruits and veggies
brightly colored foods there
there's this fascinating study five
years ago that if you walk down to a
hospital lobby and pick a hamburger and
eat it
within an hour you can document that
your arteries are dysfunctional
something called endothelial
dysfunction a rather shocking statement
that the food is served
on a patient tray directly can be shown
to harm arteries if you eat that same
burger with a big slice of lettuce or a
big slice avocado you actually don't see
that same drop
so it's kind of a rule if you're not
following a perfection diet
and you slip up you know take the
antidote and the antidote is garden
foods and produce foods and
i'm certainly not encouraging people to
eat those foods but
eat them infrequently if you are and
even balanced with
nature's own antidote right it's
it it's uh it's worth saying that all of
the
claims that are made in what the health
are validated
and backed up with citations on the what
the health website if you go to
i think is it what the health dot com or
what the health movie dot com or
something you know i'll
find i'll put it in a link in the show
notes but they'll they have a section
where you can go and they basically
parse out every claim that they make
throughout the movie and then support it
with a variety of
citations yeah and i agree and the worst
example i saw and this
got garth davis involved was a z-dog
z-dog
md this md in las vegas hospitalist
who's developed an enormous youtube
following because he can be pretty darn
funny
singing and acting like a buffoon but he
took on what the health and uh
eviscerated
not just the concept as a clearly
non-trained nutritionist
non-trained uh epidemiologist but he
made fun of the people in the movie
particularly michael clapper he was just
michael clapper one of the most
high integrity physicians at you know
practicing santa rosa
a man of such integrity and it just so
offended me that
garth uh davis responded vigorously into
youtube and a blog i responded
vigorously in a blog
and he seems i actually think the
pushback's working i've been told
that nina taikals and gary tobbs
actually read when we get angry and
they're
a little more careful about what they
say and i clearly send z-dog has
backed off which is why we need to be
vocal aggressive and sometimes obnoxious
right i think but he achieved his goal
which was to get a bunch of attention
and views right you know by being
controversial and then
garth who's a bulldog and you know god
love him that guy speaks his truth and
doesn't hold back and and you know
that's why he's
he's the best and you know you if
anybody who saw him on
on the doctor saw you know like that
that kind of went sideways for everybody
and
crazy it was like actually plant-based
nutrition
news which is a youtube channel did a
video
uh about that experience of garth on
that show
that's pretty interesting i'll link that
up in the shout outs as well everyone
just check that out because
i think garth did better than even garth
you know sort of i know garth didn't
have a good experience on the show it
was kind of a hatchet job they were
gonna come after him but
he stood his ground quite strongly and
with respect to z-dog
you know garth kind of went right back
at him and then
z-dog sort of backed down because now he
had all this attention
and realized like oh like garth actually
watched you know just watch my video
and garth was the one who said let's
debate i'll debate any time bring
anybody else or he
he wanted to debate this is how i
understand it i hope i'm not butchering
this but
gar suggested that he could come on z
dog show and debate him and then z-dog
sort of backed down and said well
you know i'm not the best person to
defend these claims
you know sort of admitting like maybe he
was a little bit out of his
element or his area of specialty and
then gar said well bring on anyone you
want and i think there was a
conversation about
maybe having rob wolf or somebody
exactly like that and then it
never came together for whatever reason
i don't know why it's probably better
just be another more attention everybody
wants to have these debates
right there's a lot of energy like let's
get all these people in a room
uh but in my experience i don't know
that that's really it's it's interesting
because we all have these silos
and in certain respects these silos are
not serving us like we do kind of need
to get together in the way that you did
at google with
dave asprey and have a mature
conversation but a lot of times
these these these conversations devolve
into
shouting matches and and everyone's so
dug in that
nobody it's like it's like watching
political television on
medical conversations should try not to
devolve
to the viewer you know they may not be
the best example i will give
on a similar path i got invited on the
doctors about a month before garth
to take on steve gundry and the plant
paradox which we haven't talked about is
worth maybe two minutes
yeah i've been sure i shared quite a bit
of my roll call email everything okay
right
yeah just you know the idea that legumes
are dangerous because they've got hidden
anti-nutrients called lectins and if you
eat five kidney beans you can die if
they're not properly cooked
and this coming from a man who was chief
of one of the more prominent
cardiovascular
departments in the united states in loma
linda kind of ironic
the center of plant-based science in the
evantas health study
now an anti-aging kind of guru out in
hot springs
california but his book got all the
accolades and i went on the show to
debate him and
i was prepped and primed and he was
relaxed
and not on his game and it was
um not the shouting match but it cleared
there
that this is another confusionist
approach to nutrition
when every blue zone eats legumes the
very center of dan buettner's chart
is legumes and every you know pocket of
centenarian length
uh let's clarify that for the public
real quick so uh that was a fun
experience not in handling the man
because i actually have esteem for him
and some of the work he's done but
for just you know trying to turn the you
know
trying to stifle that as quickly and
efficiently as
media and tv lets you do right the basic
message from that book is stay away from
beans and legumes or cook them with such
care
that you might not choose to cook them
at all because there's the the fear
has been put message everybody listening
don't eat raw beans
it's really really bad to buy a bag of
red kidney beans and eat them but i
don't know any society in the world or
any human that would
uh try and do that yeah well i'd be in
big trouble if i had to stay away from
those foods because i got those right
eat cooked ones or pressure cooked ones
or soak your beans and cook them but
there's not really much health risk with
the typical human experience or you
might get some diarrhea
and nausea if you rush the process of it
i wanted to touch on another issue that
you've been it seems to me that you've
been getting more and more interested in
which is
intermittent fasting cool great which is
not like uh
that's not a that's a subject matter
that's been embraced by
the the low carb low carbers and
ketosis people like they're all about
that there's a lot of science going on
the plant-based community hasn't really
spoken to this but i think what's going
on in that world is super interesting
super interesting and it circles back to
the conversation we had about dr
longo um you know the very brief bullet
points the observation that
our experience in humankind often were
periods of
relative starvation just on the nature
of not being grocery stores a couple
thousand years ago or ten
000 years ago and uh apparently we have
an apparatus designed to put us into a
different
antibiotic state to
handle you know calorie deprivation many
studies that suggest there's no species
in a research model that if you restrict
their calories they don't live longer
a yeast you restrict their calories they
actually live 10
times longer if you take a mouse and
restrict your calories they live
40 to 50 percent longer you know
profound differences
the question is is there a human
experience that's
possible and doable and compatible with
life and that isn't the biosphere where
you come out you know grumpy and uh
depressed and
uh and you every day of the month you
have to watch how many calories you take
and there are people that do that
so what ultimately and the only point
really to talk about because it's
another really interesting part of the
plant-based movement right now is
dr longo seeing the biosphere experience
but also enjoying life as a typical
italian
might want to be played over the years
in
in these yeast models and these mice
models and recently humans
and could we mimic fasting but still eat
provocative crazy idea could we create a
diet that doesn't have the components
that food causes that accelerates the
mtor pathway the pka pathway these
pathways that accelerate aging and
destruction of cells can we create a
diet that lets you eat some
um and can we actually still benefit
from what fasting seems to do which is
uh accelerate a process a fancy word
autophagy the clearing
of damaged cells to allow them to
function better
that process real quickly that won the
nobel prize last year autophagy
is like the hot button right now of
anti-aging
that if you eliminated every case of
heart disease cancer and diabetes would
extend human life by 13 years
if we could end damage to cells and
improve the efficiency of autophagy to
take your cells that are aging
and restore them to a youthful state
would extend human life by 30 years
so the research is going now in this
anti-aging world
and he created bottom line a diet that
five days in a row
of in the human experience 800 calories
a day
of a plant-based diet low in sugar and
low in protein but
containing whole food fats like olives
and nuts and containing
moderate complex carbohydrates so that
the carbohydrate
calorie loads about 35 percent that he
found in animal models and in a study
published february 2017 and 100 humans
that you could see the responses you get
with a complete fast but you don't have
the pain of a complete fast you don't
have the risk of a complete fast
he called that and patent that fmd
fasting mimicking diets
and he has shown that not only do they
favor losing visceral fat around your
belly
which is what so many people are doing
10 day belly bloats
five days in a row in a month and you
can do it as many months in a row as
you can tolerate and all and we're
talking about eating a nut bar for
breakfast we're talking about eating
soup and kale crackers for lunch
we're talking about eating soup and
occasionally a little cacao bar
for dinner these actually come
pre-packaged in a start-up that he
engaged in with the university of
southern california that doing that five
days in a row
activates these primal pathways that
actually not only
favor improved metabolism losing
visceral fat you don't lose muscle mass
which is fantastic but you actually
lower igf-1 levels
which is one of the goals and lastly you
actually create
a flood of stem cells from your bone
marrow into your bloodstream
stem cells that people are going to
tijuana and paying a ton of money for
that will go to injured and damaged
parts of your body and clear out damaged
cells so
there's data now in animals and some
human data that multiple sclerosis may
be responsive
to a five-day fasting mimicking diet of
plants low in sugar low in fat
that actually brain growth occurs in
animal models and right now cognition is
being studied in italy
using dr longo's five-day fasting diet
in addition to just weight loss that um
cancer patients it's called chemo leave
it's a product they've developed and not
released it's being studied at the mayo
clinic in other places
that if you're getting chemotherapy and
you do this fasting mimicking
diet and use plants and use low sugar
low fat
you actually get a better kill rate for
the chemotherapy and you get less side
effects
profound data athletes are being studied
in verona italy right now to see if this
enhances performance
if it will enhance recovery and allow
you to go back and do the next
athletic event with more success so
several hundred worldwide studies using
this exact model
i would describe it it's a plant-based
cyclical
ketogenic diet cyclical because it's
five days a month and it's plants
so it's not the extreme of what you're
seeing on the in the blogosphere
uh it's the plants and the plant
proteins that don't seem to activate
aging like animal-based protein
and it's 800 calories a day it's not
water fasting
so there are people shouldn't do it
underweight people pregnant people
brittle diabetics brittle heart patients
800 calories a day i've done it
seven of the last 11 months i'm down 25
pounds
i bound this energy my labs show
improvement my blood pressure shows
improvement
i have dozens of patients who have had
the same experience
and you know what do you do with a heavy
vegan who's really
doing it right you got to change your
metabolism and this is
one of the hacks that might uh you know
allow our movement
one to have the scientific basis to say
we're in the right sector of the food
plate
and two to actually help people get more
out of it than they're getting because
not everybody eating a whole food
plant-based diet
with oil without oil is going to achieve
their optimal blood pressure blood sugar
and weight
and we need more tools and this is one
of the tools
that's fascinating it's fascinating and
it's powerful and it's
you know as i said nobel prize nominated
science
that will one day be rewarded with the
award and
is there any indication that these uh
benefits can be enhanced by not e eating
at all or doing a multi-day fast or
is are we still just too early in the
process to understand or
like this protocol which involves eating
a little bit of food throughout the day
works just as well as completely
cutting yourself off um it was designed
to give the benefits of a complete fast
without the risk of a complete fast
because
those that are doing prolonged water
fasting certainly in the
chronic illness model are doing it in an
inpatient clinic like true north or
places in florida
um and not everybody can access that and
not everybody's gonna do that
this a person does at home i do it while
i'm working i'm seeing patients i'm at
my restaurant
you feel phenomenal at least a lot of
people feel phenomenal you can get a
little hangry
you're allowed to cheat a little with
some celery and slice cucumber
pretty uh calorie and nutrient sensing
pathway neutral food but it's a
breakthrough
and i don't think the public even has a
clue how profound a breakthrough this
is because the joy is 25 days a month
you have no rules i mean you have your
healthy diet rules
but these people that are trying you
know and dr longo would say the optimal
time restricted period is 12 hours a day
you know the days you're not doing
uh this fasting mimicking diet um you
know whether you're
totally plant-based whether you're
following a mediterranean diet the dash
diet
you know 8 a.m to 8 p.m is your feeding
period he likes breakfast and dinner
skipping lunch
we're not talking about somebody burning
6 000 calories a day training or
performance
uh we're talking about you know the
typical person out there but you
couple five days a month for optimizing
your
regenerative innate ability with 25 days
a month
and you add you know a 12 hour feeding
period you may indeed have that
longevity diet
particularly if you mimic it after you
know the native cultures the blue zone
cultures the italian culture
the stem cell aspect of that it's
fascinating i just say personally and i
know you've got to be very careful about
anecdotes i had a really refractory
plantar fasciitis and after two months
of this
it went away now it didn't go away for
the previous year
and i've had patients tell me shoulder
back and other parts there is clearly
data that
damaged nerve cells in animal models of
multiple sclerosis regrow
that damaged brain tissue and mice
models called the hippocampus regrow so
this is not totally conjectural that you
may actually heal
damaged parts of your body there's
there's actually animal data that a
animal model of type 1 diabetes where
there's no insulin produced
responds with the production of insulin
for the first time and there's no human
equivalent so no type 1 diabetic
should do this but those research
studies are underway so
fascinating yeah i'd be really keen to
see what the studies
are going to say about the impact of
this in an athletic performance context
too because the conventional wisdom is
replenish your glycogen stores and your
electrolytes and your protein within 30
minutes of of training right and this is
the way that you
bounce back as rapidly as possible but
if you can stimulate that stem cell you
know production
and and there is this what what is it uh
what's the term you used uh
of the cells sloughing off yeah
autophagy
right um what would that mean right are
you
are you literally turning the clock back
and making you a better athlete so there
is a study underway i don't know the
protocol but
yeah i argue for what i've termed and
it's nothing special vegan plus or whole
food plant-based plus
you know don't be dumb take your
supplements don't be don't get in a
situation where you're deficient in b12
because you've heard you may not need to
i think that's one play that we need to
emphasize vegan plus fasting i think is
a
not completely untouched there are
there's a facebook user's page now with
20 000 people doing ketogenic
plant-based diets
sometimes cyclical which i think is
safer go back to food
and a normal schedule um i don't know
that they're all doing that but that's a
growing uh
group um vegan plus organic you know
vegan plus no oil that you know the kind
of
enhancing this core data i think are
really fertile areas but the
the fasting is by far the most
scientifically solid
i mean huge data amazing data
i'm going to look into that a little bit
more i mean i've experimented with it
a little bit just in a very informal way
of
of like not eating until dinner you know
right
like eating one meal a day right and
doing that while training and seeing how
that
impacts my ability to recover and part
of that
is is trying to anecdotally
with an n of one study right trying to
see
if that has any positive impact on on
you know the efficiency with which i can
tap into my
anaerobic zone to like enhance my
endurance
by not so in addition to the training
that i'm doing but
through nutrition getting trying to
trick my body
into more efficiently using fat for fuel
right and if you're not eating right
that's what you're going to be
tapping into in order to propel you
through your workout well i i can't
speak for him but dr
longo is a long-distance runner so you
to my and i've never heard him talk
about
uh uh his view on that for you know
performance athletics but you'll have an
interesting conversation um
no i i think it's uh
if this were a drug that you could show
did all that's been documented
uh it would be a 20 000 a month drug and
we're talking about there is
a commercially available food kit that
he has
designed because he believes you know
it's exquisitely important what those
800 calories are and how they're
delivered and
he won't do it in powders these are
foods um
people have tried to mimic it there is a
he has a great facebook page professor
walter longo
he posts a lot of stuff a prolon is the
name of his research project they have a
website
it's very easy to find he's a very hot
commodity right now he's been written up
in the new york times and
forbes and other places and uh what
you're going to see coming out is
good stuff a lot of youtubes there's
actually a documentary that another
reason
i'm sure he'll want to talk to you call
fasting that he's featured in that's
just about to be launched
yeah and there's a lot of different
plays there's a another ucla has a
researcher dr
sachin nanda who's la is the center of
uh the serious fasting science data but
um it's a good thing to add on you know
you're unique most of us are dealing
with calorie excess
and exercise deprivation and we're
getting fat
and it's far better to skip a meal than
compromise
it's far better to learn you can go with
two meals a day
maybe breakfast dinner as a routine
which i've adopted
there's a mindset doing this that i
was not told about but darn five days
800 calories i just worked
i though this program is three meals a
day but you know they're not big by any
stretch imagination that i mean i have
the power
to eat less and feel good and achieve
the goals weight or
otherwise and i hear that from patients
all the time i've completely changed
my mindset this was breakthrough for me
psychologically as well as
physiologically
because i finally got away from you know
if food's there i won't eat it because
it's better to skip than to eat in the
culture we live in where
there's food everywhere all the time
well we've just been taught that we're
supposed to eat three meals a day like i
don't know who came up with that but you
look at ray krona he's this guy yeah
it's like yeah
30 days or whatever on water and you
know i'm not advocating that people go
out and do that but i think it's
important to like look at that and say
and and he loves it to say look our
bodies are
capable of so much more than we you know
sort of understand
and to just explore the idea of what
happens when you skip one meal or maybe
two meals and go hey i'm still breathing
air
you know the single most powerful
activity you can do to prolong your life
is eat less every day
and that's a message that is so needed
right now and then we can talk about
what that is
but start out with that in your mind
shut your mouth your kitchen your
refrigerator
and watch your health bloom let's talk
about the book
cool books just out the plant-based
solution
i just got it the other day so i i i
wasn't able to read it yet but i have
like page through it
and it's good i think people are going
to be um
really uh helped by all of it's page
restricted book just like we were
talking about calorie restricted
i don't have much patience to read
thousand
page books nor do i have the time i
don't have time to write these books so
it's about 150 pages of science of
plant-based diets and hard plants based
diets and diabetes plant-based diets and
brain and sex and
and uh autoimmune diseases like lupus
and then my wife chipped in god bless
her karen
and put together a three plus week
eating plan of recipes it's not
elegant like your amazing meal planner
uh that is
an incredible resource we all appreciate
but nonetheless
people people have asked me non-stop you
know
you have a recipe book so this is as
close as i've gotten so far some
recipes from my restaurant and uh it's
been fun it's actually gotten a lot of
attention
um and uh good feedback
yeah it's great and what i like about it
is that you've
you know you've branched out beyond just
cardiology and heart health you're
talking about
uh you know diabetes cancer autoimmune
diseases gut health
ms alzheimer's parkinson's aging
sex drive like you're hitting all the
buttons the impact of food on these
conditions
in terms of prevention and reversal yeah
and the data's there we always need more
we are a
intertwined network that's kind of the
philosophy of functional medicine that
people ask me all the time what's the
side effect of eating a
whole food plant-based diet for heart
disease a side effect is you're
probably going to be thinner more
attractive have more focus
have a better sexual performance you
know have a lower blood sugar and less
likely develop diabetes and
uh a whole series of litany so that's
the beauty of the human body
is you know uh has an amazing ability to
heal itself it will just
uh rethink you know you can't heal
plant uh and nutrition-based diseases
with pharmacology you have to heal
nutrition-based diseases with nutrition
and we're starting to wake up that the
last 50 years have been rather ugly
yeah you got a great forward by john
mackey in there
you know the guy's a gem and i don't
know him real well i met him in santa
rosa and then he actually has been
through detroit and he comes to my
restaurant and eats
so he was eating in my restaurant gave
me the forward
next day he announced the amazon deal
how he he
he you know his wonderful book the the
whole foods diet
he was planning as you know this
gigantic national tour and it all got
interrupted by his need to go back to
the business and uh
and work on the deal and announce the
deal but i mean he was just sitting
there like
like a poker player not mentioning
anything and he left and yeah i'm very
delighted that he is willing to do that
because he is a very special human being
is
he's an amazing guy and i you know i had
him on the podcast to talk about his
book
right in the middle of that proxy war
going on
and i couldn't believe that he didn't
cancel the podcast because i can't
imagine the amount of stress he was
shouldering at the time
because he was really under fire and he
didn't want to
he didn't you know he did these these
you know investors were
really just trying to do it a pump and
dump and he was
doing everything he he could in his
power to prevent that from happening
um and so yeah his
it coincided with his book coming out
which meant he couldn't do press
except for like my podcast or maybe one
or two other things
uh because he had to keep his focus on
that but then i attended
uh his conscious capitalism conference
in austin
a couple months ago and what was
fascinating about that
is that he got on stage and did a panel
with the guy from the motley
fool and and talked about like his you
know how he felt about this deal it was
the first time he'd spoken
semi-publicly about it and what was
fascinating was
some of the behind the scenes stuff
where
him you know he felt very aligned with
amazon and now he's thrilled
he's like this is the best thing for the
company and now he gets to do
what he likes doing which is like grow
the business and
not have to worry about all this kind of
stuff so i think it all ended up for the
best
it is amazing that amazon now owns whole
foods and it's
going to be fascinating to see how that
plays out yeah i i agree i mean
when campbell's buy specific organic
foods
it's amazing i mean it's just more
shells more you know uh more stress off
the uh
entrepreneurs to let them focus on you
know creativity and production
and uh who do one of the uh burger
companies just sold to canadian uh
firm i mean you know it's controversial
that sometimes these are companies that
aren't
plant-based and have a bit of a conflict
but they've got to grow
you know access the future is right to
get it in every grocery store and every
red robin and every tgifs i mean it's
it's groundbreaking that we're seeing
this happen and they're not my favorite
foods but they still
deal with the environmental and the
animal rights issue and and
some of the health issue yeah you don't
have leucine
in a impossible burger to the level you
have it in a beef burger so
you're not going to activate mtor and
all this kind of highbrow science we
talked about at the beginning
i think it's cool that campbell's has
made this really strong push
into getting into the plant-based food
world i think there's some what is it
plant-based food producers some
some like organizations that dropped out
of the general one and
entered the exclusively plant-based uh
growers group yeah which is
a phenomenal commitment and they're
serious they have a big presence
in detroit about a mile from my uh cafe
and it's growing
and they've got hundreds and hundreds of
employees in detroit in ferndale
michigan
um which is great how's the restaurant
going uh
one about to become two we're pregnant
so uh our 4 000 square foot green space
cafe
now two and a quarter years old what i
call my 401k
cafe uh um i've had this because you
you emptied your 401k yeah i don't have
anybody else with me other than my son
and he's too young to have a 401k so
i've uh
i've i've let passion dictate some of my
financial decisions i
produced a broadway play in the back
past we'll talk about that uh some
future i didn't know that
yeah that's a whole story
but i did have uh director seats on
broadway for 10 years
or producer seats um it's going very
well the public has really embraced it
what the hell drove a tremendous number
of first-timers in
because my wife and i we wander through
every night and when you've been here
before how do you like it
um we just hired a matthew kenney
trained chef which i'm very excited
about thank you matthew
of course a guest that you've
interviewed and a great force
i'm very excited and we're opening a
small fast casual place march 1 called
green space and go
so we're committed we're producing food
and
see this tipping point which clearly has
happened i mean this is
although malcolm gladwell speaks
horribly about plant-based diets
i will embrace the term tipping point of
his
out of his lexicon and um i didn't know
that he had spoken at all about this
yeah
he has a podcast and he i love malcolm
he went really deep into the nina tyco's
world and
praised her beyond any expectation on a
podcast about four months ago and
i beat him up on twitter but he didn't
respond you know that's how it goes
i've been baiting joe rogan to just put
one of us on and let us
go at it i don't mind being bloodied
come on joe
bring it on stop talking to these
orthopedic surgeons that eat meat and
don't check their labs it's a bad public
message
i will say he had chris cresser on um
a second time yeah fairly yeah recently
right
and you know we both know chris
i like chris and i found his i found
what he had to say i
i i i agreed with like 99
of what he was talking about chris is a
real good sensitive
and you know complete you know uh
medical practitioner without a doubt um
i think he distorts the science a bit
but we are all subject to that uh
criticism hello
all right fast casual where's the fast
casual it's only five miles away up
woodward avenue which you remember with
your gross point roots uh
on the yeah i haven't heard that in life
40 years
one of the coolest things in detroit is
coming up is the international auto show
which is as cool as can be
but um in the third weekend in august
they've reproduced like american
graffiti so they have this thing called
the dream cruise
and 1.5 million people bring their hot
rod cars from around the world
and drive them up and down woodward
avenue like uh in the 50s and richard
dreyfus
and we're right in that strip and so
it'll be it's about a
1600 square foot 20-seat grab-and-go
drive-through window
it's not it's not fast food it's fast
casual it's whole food
i'm pretty insistent that this is
healthy food you know we have super
foods in the salads in the bowls and the
wraps
we'll see we'll see if we can make that
okay march 1.
it's coming up cool well i love your
restaurant uh i only had the opportunity
to eat there that one time
when i came out for the plant-based
group yeah yeah
plant-based nutrition support support
group
which was an amazing experience and you
put together this incredible dinner
and the restaurant is like
super top-notch high-end the food was
like extraordinary
yeah where l.a was very little very true
yeah like it was like
i was like whoa like you're doing it
right you know like
really right and i'll just say the
coolest thing lately is professional
athletes
red wings lions uh not a kyrie
pistons we don't have kyrie irving in
but we got tobias harris
impact of kyrie yeah it's huge and but
with tobias harris
piston wonderful human in all the time
some of the red wings are coming in
we've had the coach of the pistons in
who's
you know some of these are now
plant-based athletes theoritic a detroit
lion
is now plant-based and so we're seeing
that and you know it's
i i don't know that there's fasting and
professional athletes i think are
the two coolest things going on in the
plastic plant-based world to shift the
public mind
well i think it's it's the what the
health effect like the impact on the nba
and the nfl from that movie has been
unbelievable and and i think a lot of it
has to do
with david carter like david carter
being in that movie
and what he said i think really
resonated with a lot of those guys and
it's so
fascinating to see so many of them
jumping on board i mean kyrie it's huge
did you see the nike ad
yeah it's crazy plant-based i mean it's
like the words
plant-based diet are being uttered in a
nike ad
right and it's being done in kind of a
they're sort of poking fun
you know like it is flatter thing and
all of that like but i'll take it like
that's that's kind of an amazing
cultural moment
i agree i celebrate uh
all these little a little hopeful and
again it it isn't the war that we
started with
but there is a war for the health of the
planet there is a war for the
destruction and you know the cruelty to
animals and there is a war going on
with health in america and
it matters everything we've talked about
and from the calcium score to
the saturated fat to um
industry like campbell's and others
buying up companies i mean
uh i'm i'm very optimistic as i know
when kim williams talks i mean we're
just
we're seeing this change the last
bastion is the health industry
and we're starting i see medical
students which is so ironic it's so
distorted that it's the food industry
taking the charge and the
professional athletes in the health
industry limping along like we're
talking about cigarettes and give us 25
years to change because
you know no we went through a 25-year
period before they banned smoking in
hospitals it could have been done much
earlier let's learn from that
no they argue let's reproduce it so um
that's the last bastion when medical
students
at least get a fair shake at learning
about this stuff and i'm seeing that
happen i'm seeing uh
i lectured to a group of medical
students about three weeks ago and
expected a very negative answer the
question have any of you tried eating
vegetarian or vegan
50 raised their hands and laughed are
you kidding we're full-time plant-based
like whoa i think that was an unusual
group yeah that's that gets me fired
wayne state has a program now right
wayne state is a gigantic medical school
but they will uh
they have not incorporated paul
chatlin's plant-based curriculum yet
but they're much more open i'm going
down there in a few weeks to do lunch
and learns and
some of their curriculum and some
medical schools are even doing better
than that some of the osteopathic
schools doing way better than that but
that's when the when you go to your
doctor and
even if it's three minutes of nutrition
conversation
and maybe you are directed to
nutritionfacts.org or forks over knives
or
what the health or told to read a book
like the plant-based solution or you
know how not to die or something
um you know that's the army of soldiers
we need to
really the critical issue of living the
best life as a general community that we
can offer and
greatest country in amer in the world
ought to have the greatest health
outcomes in the world and we're number
37 so
we got some work to do but interesting
times uh hopeful times
yeah all right we gotta lock this down
but i am going to
shut this bad boy uh down with one final
question that's a question i've asked
you before
it's the same question i ask every
doctor that comes on the podcast
i can't remember what you said last time
but the question is this you probably
already anticipated
if it was a parallel universe and you
woke up to be
surgeon general in this crazy
administration
uh what would you do what would be the
first thing
that you would try to change or put in
place yeah
i i would tackle and uh i didn't see it
coming
the question but i would tackle the fast
food industry and legislate i would
i guess it's all the one answer i would
take away food subsidies that create
19 mcdonald family meals that should be
and i would uh let no
buddy left standing that fought in the
way to take the dairy industry and the
meat industry and all and take away
those subsidies that allow that absurd
situation to occur
so i think that's the single first thing
i do bring some equity of pricing
and a free market back into the
production of food
which would mean some farmers in the
animal world would shut down and uh
they could be converted to yeah
politically it's what has to happen
or we're just going to keep limping
along with the same system same system
same system number two would be to
change health care to reward
prevention you know to the degree that
it should be that
you know fifteen dollars to talk to a
patient and fifteen hundred dollars to
put in the stent
and not talk nutrition uh a world that i
lived in and i was on the stent side
while i was doing
both but um is not a tenable model for
the next you know
generation all right your good man dr
joel khan
i appreciate you too sir thank you for
coming here the book is the plant-based
solution
everybody pick it up wherever you buy
your books
and get your calcium scab thank you good
plea to the public all right man come
back and uh
come back anytime we'll talk more i have
a list here of all these things i
still want to talk to you about we
didn't even get to them we're two hours
here
all right my friend peace and plants
you